oh that would be so
sweet it would be full circle
this shirt was about to go in the wash
today but we're doing a new rockstars
video so
it was like nope it's gonna be all
smelly and gross
tried to cross the barrier of your
apartment door and then just got
ripped back in i'm sure eric voss has a
gazillion of these i'm sure he doesn't
wear the one same shirt every single day
hey guys we're gonna watch today from
new rock stars because it's
one division finale week so gonna try to
cover some one division finale stuff and
see
what theories come true this is how
vision could survive
westview vision versus white vision and
also if you haven't seen our episode
eight reaction it does
probably in the description box let's do
this welcome back to the rockstars i'm
eric voss and one division just gave
vision both his biggest threat and his
possible lifeboat to a future in the mcu
in the form of white vision at least
that's what we're calling them
a secondary sentient weapon built by
white visions
and wanda's magic from that drone that
she told them to keep out of her yard
now posing a threat to wanda in the
scarlet vision that's what i'm going to
call him the hacks vision that wanda
created with her mind stone amplified
chaos magic but also
still apparently tangible enough to
trigger vibranium decay sensors on the
outside
so the two visions what my favorite
breakfast date
these are confusing times and there is
an equally confusing history with white
vision in the comics but i'm gonna
explain
what this vision versus vision battle
will probably look like in the one
division finale episode and what white
vision's arrival means for paul
bettany's employment status
so in one division white vision is the
product of project
cataract sword director tyler hayward's
secret sentient weapons project
sometime after vision's death and
wakanda and infinity war presumably in
the last three years because that's when
hayward took over
sword from the late maria rambo hayward
got a good hands on visions
desaturated remains and shifted sword's
focus
to reanimated vision into a superhero
synthesized that he could control yeah
you could try to theorize a deeper
agenda or hidden identity by hayward as
a form of ultron or the grim reaper or
mephisto
no i don't think so folks i'm ch how
dare you say he's not mephisto
but you abandon the ship everyone is
mephisto
everybody until otherwise proven
anything else
is mephisto not everything is mepisto
most things hayward is just another
government a-hole
seeing superheroes as controllable
assets kind of like what
i would love it now
to do with the iron legion certainly
there's a thematic parallel with the
ultron disaster
but really it's a mistake that every god
player falls into
hayward likely hope god damn god planned
for serious magic
and bond with vision to reboot his parts
but when she didn't do that
and made the town of west view new
jersey disappear off the map
hayward sent in monica rambo after
updating sword's front desk security
so that monica would fly a drone into
the anomaly
so that maybe hayward could snatch some
of wanda's yummy yummy magic
but then unfortunately for hayward
monica herself got sucked in
no other probes came back out with
usable magic until
the 80s stark drone something that was
already in the 80s form
didn't need to be rewritten by the
reality so in order to be disabled out
of a weapon that would hurt wanda
needed to be coded with this chaos magic
in order to keep it disabled giving
hayward the symbizoid fuel source that
he needed while this is going on hayward
whoa whoa wait a minute so is the
implication
hayward specifically hired monica
rambo just to send in a drone
you're the only one who's going to fly a
drone and get it
some magic juice like i thought like the
idea of the chaos magic
happening upon the drone when wanda came
out was all kind of
accidental and then they rolled with the
flow and then they
used the chaos imagine like hey why
don't we try this out let's put this in
the vision we've been trying to bring
back to life
yeah i mean it doesn't seem like they
would know enough about the nature
and it seems like when she brings the
drone out that's part of the key of
why it still has the magic residue on it
so like how would they know to expect
something like that i can't imagine him
wanting to get access to her magic
somehow though
i can imagine that too i don't know if
i'm just mishearing uh eric vos's words
as
saying this was purposeful and not just
hey we got lucky
let's try this out you know while this
is going on hayward lied to monica
saying wanda
did steal visions parts in order to one
make wanda look like villain and to
hide his own possession of those parts
and his whole plan to weaponize them
into project cataract white vision now
this whole plot does reflect a bit of
how white vision came about
he comes from the 1989 vision quest arc
of the west
coast avenger comics after vision had
previously taken
over the government nuclear weapons
arsenal as avengers
chairman and then relinquished it but
those government agents were still
pretty freaked out
so while wanda envisioned we're married
she wakes up one day to find vision gone
and then later finds out that the
government had kidnapped and dismantled
vision's body oh and fun fact we
later find out that those government
forces were actually being manipulated
by
immortus one of the forms of the time
traveling villain kang the conqueror now
kang
is showing up in ant-man the wasp
quantomania and rumor
is he could first appear in loki if kang
slash immortus is behind hayward here
that would be
nuts though not as nuts as hayward being
ultron or merfisto
let's keep our insanity in check if we
anyway in the comics hank pam tries to
reassemble vision remember hank pym
built ultron
i mean i've pointed this out before how
i do think that it's kind of interesting
how no one's really talking about how
the events of what's happening in juan
division and multiverse and madness will
ultimately tie
in to ant-man quantomania be king the
conqueror is a nexus being everything
about quantum realms multi-dimensions
a time traveling all that seems like it
could be
very much affected by and strongly tie
in
to hear but all we ever talk about is
doctor strange and spider-man
we don't talk about how this all will
affect the events of ant-man quantomania
remember hank pym
built ultron in ultron built vision so
he's kind of like
his grand grader let's give that all the
tony stark using the android body of the
original human torch and the brain waves
of wonder man
simon williams but now williams refuses
to give his brain waves to resurrect
vision because he said that it felt like
his soul was ripped out so without those
brain waves and with the irreparable
tissue damage
vision returns white and soulless
two words that also describe this guy by
the way this is all going down as wanda
realizes that her sons billy and tommy
are pieces of mephisto's soul
and the ag of the hardness has been
brainwashing her so wanda and she's
having a great day
separate now later in the comments she
does get a new red body from an
alternate dimension
and brainwaves from the deceased son of
miles lipton
scientist alex lipton and then the
brainwaves of simon williams do return
and merge with those as well
and thus through the magic of comic book
[ __ ] vision walks again
but based on what we are seeing in one
division that same
kind of [ __ ] might bring paul
bettany vision truly
back from the dead in the mcu yeah
bethany himself indicated that his
employment with marvel studios is
ongoing beyond wanda vision from when he
played coy about
fan theories about manchester this one
that mentions
uh mephisto i can't speak to
right now because
about getting fired our editor hydra
john pointed out that
since betany had wrapped on wandovitch
by the time this interview was recorded
for him to be
worried about getting fired would
suggest that he is still
under contract to appear in a future
marvel title now he could have said
sued or fired for violating my nda but
no he said
fired which is essentially the fear of a
guy who still has his job
so yes this one division finale i mean
that could also
just mean that you know he has an
opportunity to maybe potentially come
back you know when people have
contracts so hey in case we want to
bring you back we're going to keep you
under contract you know because we're
marvel and we might have ways of
bringing you back big universe no one
ever truly died i mean you died in
infinity war now you're back now so
you know maybe there's a chance we could
bring you back so we're just going to
keep you under contract in case we
we have an opportunity to do it all
right how's that sound i don't want to
mess that up for myself
it could just be that
[Music]
you're probably right this one division
finale is clearly setting up a vision
bowl
white vision versus scarlet vision i'm
gonna give the edge to scarlet vision
because he
has something to fight for and he is on
his home that would be so shitty
which actually does give white vision a
tactic here white vision's goal might be
to drag scarlet vision out of the hex
like a wrestler throwing his opponent
out of the ring
just imagine white vision shoving
scarlet vision's face into that hex wall
as he's screaming
but step away from this for a second
let's imagine if one division does in
house of m style with wanda
leaving this dimension escaping into a
new hex reality where she
and her boys can live in peace alongside
other mutants
including her real brother aaron taylor
johnson pietro
a house of m would vision want to live
in that
lie last they talked he seemed pretty
betrayed by her
so wanda might instead grant vision a
way to live on in his home reality the
prime mcu away from her as she leaves it
by emerging visions consciousness with
the white vision body
a vision from a separate reality not
unlike the comics
now even though wanda can seemingly
create vibranium
you see here's the thing as much as some
plot points have unveiled themselves
with reveals i'm like okay that reveal
has happened the execution didn't go
down the way i imagined it would happen
but the reveal has happened i think this
would be the most predictable version
of them all this is what everyone's
saying
white vision was a concept that some
people thought might show up in this
series
most people weren't really thinking
about it and so to have white vision
coming in episode 8
the only reason i have my doubts that
that will happen i mean i'd be happy if
it did because that means vision gets to
live on
um but the only reason i have my doubts
is it just seems like the most
predictable path
and they seem to be pretty good at
knowing what to
honor in terms of reveals and like yes
we're going to we're going to do that
thing that people have thought but then
other parts have been like no we're
going against the grain yeah that's
going to tease you by honoring something
from you know the comic and also giving
you a little bit of hope but yeah
especially now that this seems to be the
sort of obvious life raft i gotta wonder
if they're setting us up actually for
something tragic with vision maybe to
bring him back further on down the line
yeah wanda can seemingly create
vibranium out of thin air i don't think
she would be able to give him a
completely new mind stone in his head
when he's outside the hex
seems like she can create a mind stone
in that hex but outside that hex the
marine stone has been atomized still
though she is a nexus bean with magic
derived from the mind stone
and her weekly woos could be converted
into synthesized fuel from that drone on
the outside
so using that logic wanda could charm
something else as a replacement battery
in infinity war wasn't shuri
the whole goal before thanos showed up
he she was trying to figure out a way to
take out the mind stone
while keeping vision still intact yeah
so there's a way to do it without the
mind stone
what is it vos boss that's why we're
here we're there
jokes and comments you're here for the
real information
black panther 2 will have all the
secrets wanda could charm
something else as a replacement battery
perhaps
the gem in her engagement ring she could
even
engrave a little heart in it like the
heart that vision
madness vision could walk once more in
the prime mcu
longing for his love the good witch who
gave this tin man his heart back
ooh by the way if you have not already
yo yes i got it
but i got to say that go get your sure
guys
you just gotta go to your new rockstar
follow me
subscribe to rockstars for everything
wanna vision thank you for watching bye
yeah i just love that idea i i'm
actually
really hoping that the show goes that
path with it because you know the first
episode there was emphasis on the rings
we don't have our wedding rings they
create the rings
and then the whole heart on the calendar
then you find out that heart was from
the
property deed that vision purchased it
was so heartbreaking when you see that
property deed
then it would work as twofold it's like
getting the gem from the ring
and then the symbolism of the heart and
the soul given to vision
it would just make it a complete package
in a complete full circle
and very poetic if they did go down that
path with helping to restore vision
i i personally love that theory
i'm hoping they do that yeah it was the
last thing mentioned and but i'm hoping
i'm hoping that actually does happen
that would be so touching imbue that
thing with mind stone energy and then
yeah
that would be beautiful touch all of our
hearts new rock stars
subscribe to them if you haven't done so
already get yourself a shirt today from
them subscribe click our notification
bell
and so you get notified when our
reaction of the finale of one division
is up should be up friday morning last
but not least
i want to shout my man bradley bledsoe
bb
my friend he has himself a daughter a
daughter in the mail
coming this way that's how adoption
works yep
um just put them in a box and ship them
to you her name is persephone
absolutely gorgeous name i wanted her to
be called gregnita
but he opposed against it i blame your
wife she's holding you back man
i think you should take your little baby
go to california and come live with us
and leave your wife behind because the
baby's adopted you don't need your wife
or anything now
yeah you can strike out your own make a
name for badass single fathers
please don't ever show your wife shout
out
or i know you know i'm joking yes no you
can show her
uh when she's like five years old that's
right when you get the courage
her name so that's the perfect time man
anyway
thank you for being here dude i hope you
appreciate this